[Música]
ahora es la película del fundamentalismo y la
política de gobierno ultraconservador
Salò Emilio Viano analista
internacional siento los apartamentos
tanto ISO como la Universidad de George
Washington agradece a PokerStars con un
su contra-semilio en director america
de France 24 una gominola aunque entre
digamos actualizado un poco de historia
que paso y S4 noviembre 1989
hay un tomate de la embajada
El estado está terminado y el deporte forma parte de
grupa que es la despedida tiene
intención de mantener el mismo
incautación de juegos
hacer un largo tiempo pensé que iba a
pago un diodo demuestro y paro
un valores pero la reacción de los
spoletico especialmente ella le dio
perspicacia y la población Misma de Irán
le Diva lento para continuar es decir
una cantidad que se pesa un movimiento
digamos lo fructífero del punto de vista
parejos politicos hace que
[Música]
mientras Washington y Teherán Hasta la
calidad
pero claramente
si esto de la
vergüenza mutua naturalmente por su cuenta
caballo país a país
tiempo sirenes se llama eso Los
Emperador autorizado savian americano
char rendicion estabas hablando de lazos mallorca
para tratamiento
palabras dramaticas sirenas
permitir que Jade delegue la mía
Vajont para atención médica puede
interpretado como una ayuda a El
paranoifrattarsi con responsabilidad segura
ahora um claramente um
rampa con un
Y esta situación por qué posemplo
empesò y en septiembre de 1900 100 la
raza entra en Irak e Irak
claro pero has estado en nidos che
crear un pequeño ven que estaba pasando
los versos diarios de Agar para liberar al
Israel
tienes una de las camillas asus muriel
mientras que en Windows Iraq es Saddam
Hussein Heracles el tiempo fue genial
amigo del estado acabado y claramente
que siraniz padre seron se pierde
enorme y sus armadas espaciales con el
superioridad del Che tempo militar de
Irak Pero sí la rampa con comprimido
esto creo que luego lo vemos abandonado
para una comunidad internacional cuando
¿Quieres esta guerra muy hijo gritar contra
dentro del mismo
Bueno, actualmente es la celebración de eso.
también fue una ocasión paracrítica
armado has estado en nidos que marla
bandera es un insulto estadounidense a la
país De Clara
Popular contra Roseto del estado
Americano ahora se transforma es
particularmente Agno, sin embargo, en el pasado
montar una demostración contra usted sabe
atollas y en contraposición a gritar Muerte
has estado en windows y san gretardo
dictador asesino dictador es salado Yahoo
armenios, que naturalmente continúa
imponer una determinada visión del islam
arriba de la cintura y arriba Vamos a ver el
política
este evento que fue antes
paradance Fuego digamos alla ira e
Yo entreno y al odio del estado en
Windows Si estás cambiando por completo
presidente de la gerencia y va a reunirse
en el Gobierno era nemismo y es de Juegos
autoritarismo y encendido de Juegos Manera
dictatorial interna dei una cierta
visión particularmente contra las
mujeres emilio antetoste y panorama
social
y está listo por una nueva revolución un
nuevo cambio social y la base de nosotros
la estructura y yo era
brevemente la Fortaleza o ella tiene del
gobierno actualmente
que tienes un gran Seo Paolo siraniers De
masliberta de Vida expresión del deber
relevante para la comunidad de
norte internacional que observar
alguna interpretación Islam en lo alto
especialmente guía privado y mientras
si no tiene si una semana cuando mi
se comunican
con el yo y via fotografia exponente
como las mujerestian durante la era
del 79 y del taller del Shah y
Expresé y ser expresado
toda una sorpresa porque estaba vestida
como morir si se tocaba si en
colombia en paris y londres vales en
manera occidental no es lo que pensé
que existió y negro y son
ha sido un meditate de ir ahora
me gustaria el sistema guardian ireneide e
al deseo de la gente por la que cambiaría
un escenario en la noche siempre que esté claro claro
el gobierno sostiene y los espías sostienen el
guardia revolucionaria sostiene el hamsito
y una tarde solo smuertos e
en las últimas manifestaciones